[Música]
quando fiquei grávida da minha filha que
está aqui na platéia inclusive eu tinha
aqui e eu estava no segundo ano do
ensino médio
e muitas pessoas me falaram tudo colocou
o seu futuro no lixo e se a gente for
pensar que essa é uma época que a gente
está pensando no nosso futuro no
vestibular nas nossas opções de vidas de
vida eo que a gente pode escolher pra
gente eu tinha na verdade uma pergunta
muito maior do que todo mundo que eu vou
fazer do meu futuro não é que essas
pessoas estivessem na verdade me
desejando mal elas na verdade estavam
avaliando a minha vida pelos
estereótipos pela maioria e pela
realidade que a gente conhece de muitas
mães adolescentes
infelizmente naquela época não só eu
tive professores maravilhosas que
continuarão incentivando teve uma filha
que nasceu no dia do professor
eu acho que isso diz muito sobre o
processo que o papel que ela tem na
minha vida
no processo de desenvolver time edu k
mas eu também uma série de mulheres que
lhe serviram de exemplo e que me
apoiaram e me inspiraram essas mulheres
minha prima a psicóloga do colégio as
madrinhas da tati minha mãe minhas
colegas
elas me mostraram que eu podia mais
tanto através do exemplo do trabalho de
incentivo delas
isso fez toda a diferença pra mim eu
aprendi que a educação é na verdade se
baseia não mais do que ensino técnico
mas também na parte de exemplo e de
apoio e que isso forma um conjunto muito
maior do nosso empreendimento all de
educação e como eu disse
fez muita diferença educação é poder
a educação em poderão e ela poderá
quando ela amplia as nossas
possibilidades a gente pode mais a gente
reflete sobre o que a gente pode a gente
pensa melhor sobre as nossas opções
sobre nosso futuro e sobre o que a gente
quer
eu gosto muito de uma frase que procurei
na internet e vi que era atribuída para
várias pessoas diferentes que é você não
pode ser aquilo que você não vê nessa
época
se a gente for pensar até pouco tempo
atrás a gente não tinha tantas mulheres
em evidência
então é óbvio que na hora da gente
pensar o que a gente podia
a gente estava cego para muitas dessas
possibilidades muitas das oportunidades
que nós mulheres e algumas de vocês
mulheres
a gente tinha em relação às nossas vidas
eu gosto muito de um conceito da marca
nos bancos e recomendo vocês conheceu
ela é uma filosofia muito famosa e uma
das minhas mulheres favoritas e que me
inspira muito
é o conceito de preferências adaptativas
que é quando a nossa história o nosso
background os nossos conceitos nossos
valores nossas crenças mas também a
nossa baixa autoestima
nosso medo tudo isso não dê de forma as
nossas opções
as nossas escolhas ao longo da nossa
própria vida então eu confesso que se eu
fosse me analisar e olha pra mim apenas
como uma adolescente grávida
eu na verdade limitar muito as minhas
possibilidades ea partir do momento que
eu tive um monte de gente servindo de
exemplo pra mim mostrando que eu podia
mais
eu de fato por demais em 2012 eu resolvi
criar um projeto que depois se
transformou num negócio social que
trabalhava justamente com isso o
empoderamento de mulheres como eu fazia
isso
na verdade trazia uma série de
palestrantes do evento para falar sobre
empreendedorismo carreira e negócios
porque acreditava que este era o caminho
pra gente amplie as possibilidades
dessas mulheres não só através de mais
exemplos de apoio mas também de poder
financeiro do poder econômico
essa empresa tinha três pilares conteúdo
na turquia e inspiração
então a gente tinha um papel muito
importante na parte do desenvolvimento
de competências técnicas dessas mulheres
a gente tinha um papel muito importante
na inspiração colocar mulheres em
evidências de mais mulheres nos palcos
dos eventos e buscar mais mulheres na
mídia mais mulheres sendo referências
nas suas áreas de atuação e isso fez uma
diferença enorme ao longo do projeto
porque a platéia conseguiu se
identificar com quem estava aqui porque
ela conseguia perceber que assim como
aquela pessoa estava aqui na frente
no palco ensinando mostrando que tinha
feito elas também poderiam fazer isso e
ao longo de cinco anos o jogo de damas
teve um papel fundamental no meu
desenvolvimento principalmente no
desenvolvimento dessas mulher
gente organizou eventos a em quatro
regiões brasileiras em mais de 20
cidades ea gente teve diretamente mais
de 12 mil mulheres presentes e seremos
foram mais de 300 palestrantes mais de
300 mulheres que serviram de inspiração
e exemplo para outras mulheres ea outra
tudo um projeto que começou
completamente sem nenhuma ambição até
porque eu não achava que eu poderia ter
um são que cresceu e se transformou num
dos principais projetos do brasil na
área de empoderamento econômico e
profissional feminino
eu e experiências incríveis em função
disso eu fui falar sobre
empreendedorismo feminino num presídio
de mulheres são mulheres que elas não
acham que têm opções se a gente já tem
acho que tem pouca se imagina essas
mulheres e elas gostaram muito e falaram
que elas se sentiam mais capazes
eu também fui falar no fórum mundial de
direitos humanos do marrocos que como
vocês devem imaginar mesmo que nosso
país ainda tem um caminho muito grande a
percorrer em termos de equidade de
gênero no marrocos é muito mais
então foi uma experiência muito legal
nesse meio tempo além de tudo isso em
função do meu trabalho eu fui convidada
para o evento da onu em nova york para
falar sobre e ela fala não é desculpa
para discutir o empoderamento
profissional econômico feminino
e pra quem estudava relações
internacionais obviamente foi uma
experiência maravilhosa
o fato de trazer várias mulheres para os
eventos há na verdade começou a gerar
uma discussão muito grande e eu fiquei
pensando será que o meu papel educar
essas mulheres como se elas não tivessem
algum tipo de educação será que é meu
papel servir de exemplo eu achava que
não eu entendia que todas nós umas às
outras e não servir de exemplo pra gente
mas mais do que isso mas o que nos
enxergar os capazes a gente mostrar para
a sociedade uma série de mulheres que
não estavam em evidência e que também
eram capazes de educar pelo exemplo foi
essa maneira que a gente percebeu que o
jogo de ida mas tinha um papel muito
importante na transformação da vida
dessas mulheres
aqui a gente tem seis mulheres incríveis
a janaina audrey aruã a michelle a crise
ea fab
todas elas participaram de um projeto de
tcc que foi feito sobre a as iniciativas
que eu tinha e o que elas falaram
elas falaram que foi fundamental para
que elas começassem a acreditar nas suas
competências foi fundamental para que
elas acreditarem nelas mesmos e que elas
reconhecessem os seus próprios méritos
elas falaram que eu era de aprender pela
prática de aprender por uma experiência
de verdade e não só aquilo que a gente
coloca no papel porque o papel aceita
tudo
mas a realidade é bem mais complexo do
que a gente tem no papel e uma delas
disse uma coisa que me marcou muito
ela teve a oportunidade de aprender
aquilo que ela não aprende nas
universidades
isso me traz para uma outra realidade
hoje já verdade algum bom tempo nós
mulheres somos mas somos maioria do
ensino superior e na pós graduação
mas quando a gente vai na verdade como
se traduz no mundo real não se traduz de
maneira tão positiva porque a gente de
fato não têm mulheres na mesma proporção
que a gente tem na sociedade ocupando
espaços de poder seja poder político
poder econômico poder social e muitas
vezes é porque a gente acha que a gente
não pode o que a sociedade acha que a
gente não pode
e como é que a gente faz para mudar
esses números como que nós enquanto
sociedade podemos olhar para essa metade
da população e acreditar que essa metade
da população também pode porque é
importante poder buscar o exemplo seja
um exemplo vocês enquanto mulheres
servem de exemplo para outras mulheres
essa questão da empatia de mostrar que
assim como tu podes outras podem fazer
uma diferença enorme
seja por uma mulher que está em casa a
campanha do marido e que deu disse que
depois através da participação dela no
projeto
ela começou até a própria renda e se
sentiu capaz ela sentiu que ela podia
sair de casa e se autossustentar não
existe uma série de maneiras que a gente
pode fazer isso e eu diria que o
principal é buscar o exemplo seja um
exemplo
a gente tem que transformar a educação a
gente tem a responsabilidade de ampliar
as nossas perspectivas enquanto educação
a gente tem que educar para a
possibilidade a gente tem que educar
pelo exemplo a gente tem que educar para
poder buscar o exemplo seja um exemplo
ao longo da minha trajetória de mulheres
incríveis que servirão de exemplo pra
mim e espero que elas tenham a noção do
tamanho desse domingo por todo esse
tempo não são delas teve na minha vida
porque se não fosse ela eu me enxergar
enxergar um futuro cheio de barreiras e
elas na verdade me ajudaram a tirar as
barreiras que achava que existiam mas
que não estavam lá e elas umas às outras
começaram a se ajudar e hoje tem uma
rede enorme de mulheres que acham que
são capazes de alguma coisa porque elas
virão outras mulheres são capazes de
alguma coisa
buscar o exemplo seja um exemplo muito
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]